So I'm just going to sketch out at a high level how Merle chooses to do this.
So first we're going to look at the data structure for a graph.
We're going to store the graph with a CSR-like structure, similar to how we'd store a sparse matrix.
So let's look at this graph here; notice it has 9 nodes,
and it has links that are either unidirectional or bidirectional,
and we're going to consider beginning our breadth first traversal with this particular node right here, node 0.
We're going to store 2 arrays to represent the graph.
The first, called C, tells us the neighbors for each node.
Node 0 has neighbors 1 and 3, so we see 1 and 3.
Node 1 has neighbors 0, 2, and 4; 0, 2 and 4 and so on.
The second array, called R, tells us the starting location for each vertex's neighbors.
Node 0's neighbors started off set 0.
Node 1's neighbors started off set 2.
Node 2s neighbors started off set 5 and so on.
As a function of V, the number of vertices, and E, the number of edges in the graph,
how long is C and how long is R, in terms of the number of elements in the array?